à 22 ans baptiste flore y est employé
agricole études terminées pas encore
installé alors depuis trois ans et demi
il partage son temps entre la ferme
familiale et un second employeur ça me
plaît puis
on voit autre chose qu'on change je suis
mon père on est plus élevage qu'on a
presque pas de culture l'aja a pris à un
peu plus sa culture enfin j'ai un petit
peu quoi une solution rendue possible
par un groupement d'employeurs agricoles
la structure verse chaque mois un smic
au jeune homme et lui partage son temps
entre les deux exploitations planning
lundi mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi avec
ton père comme ça on confirme chaque
agriculteur est ensuite facturés en
fonction du nombre d'heures effectuées
par baptiste ici cet exploitant n'aurait
pas eu les moyens d'embaucher un salarié
à temps plein pour lui cette formule
présente de nouveaux avantages elle
amène beaucoup de souplesse en termes de
gestion des emplois du temps puisque on
adapte en fait les plannings de travail
et au calendrier des travaux
c'est-à-dire pendant la moisson il va
être plus présent sur mon exploitation
est un peu moins agir et à des périodes
un peu plus calme sur l'exploitation
dans le morvan jean luc fleury a déjà un
salarié à mi-temps les jours où baptiste
est présent c'est donc une aide
complémentaire et le contenant permet à
l'éleveur de se décharger des
contraintes administratives au niveau de
l'élevage n'a pas des revenus suffisants
pour employer des talents des salariés à
temps plein en général quoi c'est assez
complexe
la part qui a employé au niveau des
salaires au niveau des cotisations
sociales et tout ça c'est très complexe
et on a pas on n'a pas assez de temps
pour une solution provisoire qui permet
à jean luc lory de continuer à
travailler avec son fils tout en
préparant petit à petit la reprise de
l'exploitation familiale